I have a question about nuts. I kind of forgot like there was a group of nuts for either tree nuts
or ground nuts. One of those were not the good ones that are good for you.
Well, the ground nuts, like peanuts and things, you have to be careful of
different fungus and aflo toxins and things in those. So that's the biggest thing for those.
Soking them will help with that. I know some nutritionists that say peanuts were never supposed to
be consumed by humans. I don't take that heart of a stance. I do think they are a food and yes,
they do carry different molds. You have to be careful of that, especially if you have some
mold issues or people that have lime should probably have to be much more conscious of that.
People with cancer, that's not a bigger issue, unless mold or something like that was the
driver of your cancer. But is it like a toxicity or something that could make it unhealthy in general
for people? Well, it's really the molds that it could make it unhealthy in general for people.
But then you go, okay, should I stay away from peanuts because they have molded them and I could have
it up with mold issues. Or the little bit of mold in a peanut, is that necessarily bad?
Could it be stimulating my immune system to create antibodies against mold? So I actually have
a greater tolerance to mold. So you know what I mean? You can balance that out. Not everything that
is bad for you is necessarily bad for you in small doses. Isn't there mold in mushrooms then too?
There are. Yep. There's mold in mushrooms. So if you're eating mushrooms from the store,
some people that have mold issues and lime issues. So they have biotoxid issues. I have to take them
off of mushrooms, off of peanuts, off of anything that could have molded them. But a healthy person
does biotoxid issues. Eating mushrooms can help stimulate the body's ability to
develop antibodies to that substance. It's the same theory that is not a theory. It's a proven
fact of why the thought that vaccines would work. If we give a small amount of the substance,
let's say the measles to the person and they stimulate it's it's enough to stimulate a TH1
and a TH2, which is a B cell reaction to the immune system, that then they'll create antibodies
against measles. Now they'll have immunity to measles. The problem comes in is that when you
put it in a little vial at how much are you going to dose that person with that amount of measles.
If you give them a little too much, they're going to get a full bone case of measles.
And now you did it helps the person. You just gave them measles. If you give them too little,
then it doesn't stimulate in a immune response to the measles at all. And they don't create antibodies.
So then what they did with vaccines is they said, well, we'll put an adjuvant in with it. And that's why
they put formaldehyde, mercury, aluminum, and all this crap that you get per ounce. Well,
all these different chemicals, those are adjuvunks that they have to put in that vaccine because they
put such a small amount of the measles in there that no one would develop antibodies against it. But
when they add the adjuvunks as well, then in a greater percentage of the population, it will stimulate
the immune response. And you're not going to develop antibodies against mercury and aluminum,
and properly guy call and for vialdehyde. But you'll stimulate an antibody against the living
organism that was accompanied with that vaccine. In this case, we're talking about measles. So then
you hope that they develop antibodies to measles. And if you develop antibodies to measles,
and you have circulated antibodies to measles, now when you're exposed to measles, you won't get
measles because you have antibodies against it. Your immune system will be more readily to kill it.
That's the whole idea with a vaccine. The problem is it just doesn't always work that way. So
the percentage of people that actually develop antibodies to the thing that they're vaccinated against
is actually quite small. So all you're doing is exposing people to all these toxic adjuvunks,
and if they have detox pathways that are blocked, those toxic adjuvunks can settle in the brain,
can settle in other tissues and cause other problems. And that's what's going on with vaccines.
However, you're basically vaccinating yourself against bad things by exposing yourself to bad things,
get small doses. Hence the benefit of teaching your kids to go out and play in the dirt,
like you did as a child, is very beneficial because they're exposed to bacteria, toxins,
and molds that are in the ground, and their body reacts to them. Not enough to make them sick,
but there's enough in their bloodstream that their immune system fires a reaction to it.
The B cells fire a reaction and you make antibodies against those things and you've
strengthened the person's immune system because the definition of a strong immune system is you have
a lot of circulated antibodies against a lot of things. When we live in such a sterilized environment,
and we sterilized our atmosphere, and we're not exposed to small amounts of toxins
that you'd never develop antibodies against it, and you are going to be more susceptible to disease
because of that. So there's my soapbox about speech about vaccination, but it's the same thing with
exposure to mold, so I personally eat peanuts. I personally eat lots of mushrooms because I want
that exposure to molds and toxins, so I develop antibodies, so I don't end up with mold problems
if I'm exposed to them in my house or in the yard or in the ground somewhere. So is it perfect? No,
but I want circulated antibodies to mold. So at other things, and so do you. That's the definition of
a healthy immune system. So if they tried harder, could they have come up with some other
additives besides the toxic ones? Oh, absolutely. So it's really not even trying harder, they do it.
The problem is is that how do you make 10 million of them and send them out to the population?
So the truth is, how do you know a six-year-old who's getting their smallpox, the vaccine,
or whatever they get at six-years-old anymore, we didn't vaccinate any of our kids? But if you're
every one of those six-year-olds in second grade are getting the exact same dosage, whether they weigh
110 pounds or they weigh 60 pounds. Because our healthcare system is so not personalized anymore,
they're in a quandary. All right, we'll just put all this crap in there to hopefully stimulate
immune response with everybody. So they're mass-producing this stuff and you can't mass-produce. Back
of the old days when the vaccines came out, they used to vaccinate someone and then they'd do a
blood draw two weeks later to see if that person developed antibodies against the thing you've
vaccinated against. And if they didn't develop antibodies against, the vaccine didn't work. Well,
guess what? They stop doing that because most of the time the vaccine doesn't work. Why do you think
these outbreaks of measles that took place in every single year, which they blame the unvaccinated
people, which to me is absolutely mind-boggling, and these outbreaks and measles occurred in the
vaccinated population? Because just because you're vaccinated against something doesn't mean you
develop antibodies. Therefore, you don't have an immune, you don't have immunity to that thing.
So it's, I just have a hard time understanding why would they choose mercury
when they could have used something else? Like why would someone intentionally do that when they
know it's harmful? Well, because they need something that's that's that's a poison that will stimulate
immune reaction. And you have to put some sort of poison in there that will stimulate
immune reaction. Okay.